the next opening we're going to be
looking at is from White and it's Pawn
to D4 Pawn to D5 Bishop F4 Knight F6 and
then Knight 2 F3 this is the London
system doesn't have to be in this
specific order but it's all about
getting these pieces and pawns to these
specific squares typically the dark
Square Bishop for white is one of the
least common utilized minor pieces in
the game and so having an opening you
always want to have more than one de 4
opening in your repertoire besides the
Queen's Gambit that's very very common
but Bishop here to F4 kind of changes
things up and definitely a very very
solid opening to have for white in your
opening
repertoire